heavy snow and fierce winds from a
historic winter storm are creating
whiteout conditions along Northern
California's major mountain roads the
National Weather Service says the storm
could bring 75 mile per hour wind gusts
and up to seven feet of snow with
dangerous blizzard conditions in
elevated communities surrounding Los
Angeles how often does it snow in
Southern California seen only once
before in 1989 which brought snow days
and traffic jams throughout Southern
California similar to what the storm is
beginning to do now creating Road
nightmares white SUV looked like it slid
over two lanes authorities are warning
the storm is only going to intensify as
it moves South this weekend bringing
danger to California's Agricultural
Center